Every week developers release new open
source tools that improve how we build,
automate, and manage software systems.
This weekly update highlights top
trending open source and best dev tool
projects this week so you can quickly
discover useful tools without spending
hours searching. From AI agents to
developer tooling and workflow systems,
these projects are gaining attention in
the open source community. Without
wasting time, let's get started.
>> Before we jump into today's project
updates, here's a quick announcement for
everyone. We've launched a brand new
YouTube channel called AI Agent Studio,
dedicated entirely to AI agent projects,
tutorials, and tools. So, if you're
interested in staying up to date with
the latest AI agent open source
projects, learning how to build your own
agents, or exploring cutting-edge agent
frameworks, make sure to check it out.
Subscribe now to get weekly videos,
in-depth guides, and real-time project
breakdowns. The link is right there in
the description. Don't miss it. All
right, let's get into today's video.
Project number one, page agent, AI agent
for interacting with live web pages.
Page agent is an open source AI agent
designed to interact directly with web
pages through a browser environment. It
observes page structure, understands
content, and performs actions like
clicking, navigating, and extracting
data using language model reasoning. The
system connects models with browser
automation so tasks execute step-by-step
inside real web interfaces. Developers
use it to automate workflows and build
agents that operate on dynamic websites.
This helps teams move beyond static APIs
into real user-like automation. Run page
agent to automate tasks directly on web
pages. Project number two, Trivy,
security scanner for code, containers,
and infrastructure. Trivy is an open
source CLI security scanner that detects
vulnerabilities, misconfigurations, and
secrets across software environments. It
scans container images, file systems,
repositories, and Kubernetes setups by
analyzing dependencies and configuration
files. The tool integrates into CI
pipelines so scans run automatically
during development and deployment. It
processes data locally and produces
reports that highlight real security
risks before release. This helps
developers and devops teams shift
security checks earlier in the workflow.
Use Trivy in your pipeline to identify
and fix security issues early. Project
number three, Chat SDK framework for
building AI chat interfaces. Chat SDK is
an open source framework that helps
developers build AI-powered chat
applications using modern web stacks. It
provides pre-built UI components and
backend utilities that connect language
models with streaming chat interfaces.
Developers integrate it with frameworks
like Next.js and connect to AI providers
for message handling and response
generation. The system manages chat
state, streaming responses, and UI
updates in real time. This helps teams
quickly create conversational
applications without building everything
from scratch. Start building your AI
chat interface with Chat SDK. Project
number four, Swift Agent Skills, skill
library for AI coding assistants in
Swift. Swift Agent Skills is an open
source collection of reusable skills
that guide AI coding assistants when
generating Swift code. It defines
structured instructions and patterns
that help models understand Swift
syntax, APIs, and UI frameworks.
Developers integrate these skills into
AI tools so generated code follows
consistent conventions and best
practices. The system improves how
assistants produce Swift UI layouts and
application logic. This helps iOS
developers get more reliable
AI-generated code. Add Swift Agent
Skills to your assistant and improve
Swift code generation. Project number
five, vectorsearch.js,
lightweight vector search library for
the browser. Vectorsearch.js
is an open source JavaScript library
that enables vector similarity search
directly in the browser. It allows
developers to store embeddings and
perform nearest neighbor searches
without external databases. The library
runs entirely client-side and uses
efficient algorithms to compare vectors
and return relevant matches. Developers
integrate it into web apps for semantic
search, recommendations, or local AI
features. This removes the need for
backend vector databases in lightweight
use cases. Add vectorsearch.js
to your app and run semantic search
locally. Project number six, Better
Result, utility for handling success and
error states in TypeScript. Better
Result is an open source TypeScript
utility library that provides structured
handling of success and error outcomes.
It introduces a result pattern where
operations return type success or
failure values instead of throwing
exceptions. Developers use it to manage
control flow more predictably across
asynchronous and synchronous code. The
library integrates with TypeScript
projects and improves readability when
dealing with complex error handling
logic. This helps teams write safer and
more maintainable code. Use Better
Result to simplify error handling in
your TypeScript apps. Project number
seven, Vite Pluse, enhanced development
toolkit built on Vite. Vite Pluse is an
open source development toolkit that
extends Vite with additional features
for modern web development. It provides
enhancements around configuration,
plugins, and project structure to
simplify setup and improve developer
workflows. Developers use it as a
foundation for building front-end
applications with faster iteration and
streamlined tooling. The system builds
on Vite's dev server and bundling
capabilities while adding extra
utilities. This helps teams manage
projects with less manual configuration.
Try Vite Pluse to streamline your
Vite-based development setup. Project
number eight, Open Squirrel, framework
for building autonomous AI agents. Open
Squirrel is an open source framework
designed to build autonomous AI agents
that can plan and execute tasks. It
provides abstractions for defining
agents, connecting tools, and managing
workflows during execution. The system
coordinates reasoning steps, tool usage,
and task progression while interacting
with language models. Developers use it
to create agents that operate across
environments and perform multi-step
operations. This helps teams experiment
with autonomous agent systems in real
applications. Build your first
autonomous agent with Open Squirrel.
Project number nine, Lite LLM, unified
interface for calling multiple language
models. Lite LLM is an open source
library that provides a consistent API
for interacting with multiple language
model providers. It acts as a proxy or
SDK that standardizes requests across
services like OpenAI, Azure, and others.
Developers send requests using a single
format while Lite LLM routes them to the
correct provider and handles responses.
It supports logging, retries, and cost
tracking during execution. The system
can run locally or as a proxy server in
production environments. This helps
teams switch models without changing
application code. Integrate Lite LLM to
simplify multi-model workflows. Project
number 10, Roofline, flow-based system
for building AI pipelines. Roofline is
an open source system designed to build
AI workflows using flow-based
programming concepts. It allows
developers to define nodes that
represent processing steps and connect
them into pipelines that handle data and
model execution. The system manages how
information flows between nodes while
coordinating execution across the
pipeline. Developers use it to design
structured AI processes without writing
complex orchestration code. This helps
teams visualize and manage AI workflows
more easily. Use Roofline to create and
manage your AI pipelines. Project number
11, Strix, platform for building and
running AI agents. Strix is an open
source platform that helps developers
create and run AI agents with structured
workflows. It provides tools to define
agent behavior, connect external
services, and manage execution across
tasks. The platform coordinates how
agents process inputs, call tools, and
produce outputs while maintaining
workflow state. Developers use it to
build agent-based systems that integrate
reasoning and automation. This helps
teams move from simple prompts to
structured AI applications. Build and
deploy your AI agents using Strix.
Project number 12, Trading Agents,
multi-agent system for financial market
analysis. Trading Agents is an open
source framework that simulates multiple
AI agents working together to analyze
financial markets. It defines agents
with different roles that process market
data, generate insights, and collaborate
during decision-making. The system
coordinates interactions between agents
and manages how information flows
through the analysis pipeline.
Developers and researchers use it to
experiment with AI-driven trading
strategies and market simulations. This
helps explore collaborative intelligence
in financial contexts. Run Trading
Agents to test multi-agent market
analysis. Project number 13, Ferme's
Agent, persistent AI agent with
long-term memory and tool access.
Ferme's Agent is an open source
autonomous AI agent that runs
continuously and assists with real-world
tasks across environments. It connects
to interfaces like terminal sessions and
messaging platforms while executing
commands through local shells, Docker,
or remote systems. The agent stores
long-term memory as reusable skill
documents that how tasks are completed,
allowing it to improve over time.
Developers use it to automate workflows,
manage systems, and run background
operations. This enables a persistent AI
assistant that learns from experience.
Deploy Fermyon's agent and run your own
long-running AI operator. Project number
14, Git Nexus, tool for analyzing and
navigating Git repositories. Git Nexus
is an open-source developer tool that
helps analyze and explore Git
repositories more effectively. It
provides ways to understand repository
structure, relationships between files,
and code evolution over time. Developers
use it to navigate complex codebases,
inspect dependencies, and gain insights
into project organization. The system
processes repository data and presents
it in a structured format for easier
exploration. This helps engineers work
faster in large or unfamiliar projects.
Use Git Nexus to explore and understand
your codebase. Project number 15,
Temporal Core SDK, core engine for
building durable workflows. Temporal
Core SDK is an open-source core library
that powers durable workflow execution
in Temporal applications. It provides
the underlying engine that manages
state, retries, and task execution for
long-running workflows. Developers build
applications on top of higher-level SDKs
while this core handles workflow
orchestration and fault tolerance. The
system ensures that processes continue
reliably even during failures by
persisting execution state. This is
essential for building resilient
distributed systems. Use Temporal Core
SDK to power reliable workflow
execution. Project number 16, Temporal
UI, web interface for managing Temporal
workflows. Temporal UI is an open-source
web application that allows developers
to monitor and manage workflows running
on Temporal. It displays workflow
execution history, task states, and
system activity in a visual interface.
Developers use it to inspect running
processes, debug issues, and understand
workflow behavior in real time. The UI
connects to Temporal backends and
retrieves workflow data for
visualization. This helps teams maintain
visibility into distributed systems. Run
Temporal UI to monitor your workflow
executions. Project number 17, Sentinel,
monitoring and alerting system for
infrastructure and services. Sentinel is
an open-source monitoring tool designed
to track infrastructure and service
health. It collects metrics and system
data, then evaluates conditions to
trigger alerts when issues occur.
Developers configure checks and rules
while the system continuously observes
services and report status changes. It
integrates with environments where
uptime and reliability are critical.
This helps teams detect problems early
and respond quickly. Deploy Sentinel to
monitor your systems and services.
Project number 18, Plausible Analytics,
privacy-focused web analytics platform.
Plausible Analytics is an open-source
web analytics platform that provides
website insights without tracking
personal data. It runs as a lightweight
web application that collects page views
and visitor metrics using simple
scripts. Data is stored and processed on
self-hosted or managed infrastructure
without cookies or invasive tracking.
Developers and site owners use it to
understand traffic patterns while
maintaining user privacy. The interface
presents metrics in a clean dashboard
for easy analysis. Deploy Plausible
Analytics and track your site without
compromising privacy. Project number 19,
SwiftFormat, tool for formatting Swift
source code. SwiftFormat is an
open-source tool that automatically
formats Swift code according to
consistent style rules. It parses Swift
source files and rewrites them to match
defined formatting guidelines.
Developers integrate it into build
processes or editors to ensure code
style remains consistent across teams.
The tool helps maintain readability and
reduces manual formatting effort in
Swift projects. This improves code
quality and collaboration in iOS and
macOS development. Run SwiftFormat to
standardize your Swift codebase. Project
number 20, Zeabur, platform for
deploying and managing applications
easily. Zeabur is an open-source
platform that helps developers deploy
and manage applications with minimal
configuration. It provides a system
where projects connect to
infrastructure, build automatically, and
run as managed services. Developers push
code and the platform handles
deployment, service setup, and runtime
management. It supports multiple
application types and simplifies cloud
operations through a unified interface.
This helps teams focus on building
features instead of managing
infrastructure. Deploy your application
using Zeabur and simplify your workflow.
Thanks for watching. See you in the next
weekly dev tool update.